hey guys i am jess mcdonald it's the
16th of april you watching games but
news and this is not a green screen what
it needs is testing my beyond good and
evil fandom the game director has teased
concept art for the second installment
hints have been dribbling in about this
one for years but game director Michelle
Unseld himself revealed the arc during a
live stream with the Rayman legends dev
team we're still getting promises that
the game will be coming to ps4 xbox one
wii u and pc but we've been hurt so many
times before that a lot of you echoed
spike 69 58 comment on gamespot which
read at this point this has become
another one of those I'll believe it
when I see it games I hope it does one
day reach my disc tray but I'm not gonna
hold my breath next up the Last of Us
remastered on ps4 has a release date and
lucky for us it's pretty soon target
games why and best via all listing the
game with a release date of june twenty
although amazon has it down as december
31st hard to say just yet whether this
is a placeholder date but we're
currently reaching out for confirmation
from sony so we'll let you know ASAP and
now a dev has said that the future of
gaming is also coincidentally exactly
the kind of game but they work on funny
how that works out candy crush dev Tommy
palm has said free to play and micro
transactions are the future of gaming
explaining the microtransaction model is
so strong and it's definitely a much
better model I think all companies have
to transition to that palm also thinks
hardcore gamers are going to come around
to this way of thinking and understand
that the games as a service model where
the title is more of a platform for
delivering regular content is better he
added I think the companies it is very
important to find a good balance free or
play games are difficult to do and you
really need to be good at making it feel
balanced to the gamers so it's not too
greedy this insinuates that he thinks
players shouldn't be forced to pay or
encounter paywalls to prevent them from
playing home rounded off by citing
blizzards hearthstone as free-to-play
done right let me know how you feel
about this model being the future of
gaming
in the comments and finally oculus
creator Palmer Luckey has creeped
everybody out today by saying that if
you can perfectly simulate reality why
do you need to go and see people in real
life luck he added that he thinks that
VR must expand to touch based
human-to-human interaction and not
strictly be a visual experience he noted
that VR could end up blurring the line
between fantasy and reality making it
unnecessary to interact in the real
world lucky also said he thinks
traditional TV and wanted to displays
will be replaced by virtual reality in
the next 10 to 20 years and a while
isn't mass market yet people are
beginning to see the potential let me
know whether you reckon virtuality is
going to take off or not in that comment
section down below or if you prefer you
can talk to me directly on Twitter where
I'm at just McDonald those are all the
things that I have to tell you about
today but tomorrow I'll be back with
even more gaming news so check back with
me then